San Francisco's Japantown is home to some origami masters,...
...including Linda Tomoko Mihara.
Linda is a third-generation Japanese-American.
She is famous for her origami cranes, which once played an important role in Japanese culture.
It was tradition for the bride to fold 1,000 cranes...
...to wish for a long, prosperous marriage, and also to demonstrate...
...I guess her patience.
Linda's grandparents compiled the first origami handbook ever published in the United States.
She began doing origami at the age of five.
She and Lang have worked together.
They once created all the origami models for a 3D animated commercial.
Everything you saw in that commercial, except the car, was origami.
So we did buildings, city buildings, Victorian houses,...
...and even the decorations in the streets around the houses:...
...trash cans, potted plants, and street lamps.
The great response that the commercial got has further spurred the two artists' passion to create.
They are now hoping to one day do the first ever origami movie.
For Producer Suli Yi in San Francisco, Ruth Reader, VOA news.